بالنسبة لمونيكا دياز ، فإن كل يوم هو صراع
هي بلا مأوى وتحمل معه الكثير مما تملكه
لكنها تقول
إن ثقل إدمانها هو أنه في
بعض الأحيان يكون أكثر من اللازم ، فقد
تناولت جرعة زائدة في الماضي في الماضي ليس
هنا ولكن  في الماضي ، كان هذا هو
المكان الذي يُنسب إليه دياز لمساعدتها في التأقلم ،
إنه موقع استهلاك مخدرات خاضع للإشراف
أول موقعين يتم افتتاحهما في البلد ،
كم مرة
تزورون فيها أبوابهم خمسة أيام في الأسبوع ، أنا
هنا كل يوم  كل يوم ، نعم
والأيام التي
لا يكونون فيها مفتوحين ، ما الذي تفعله
للارتجال في
كلا الموقعين في مدينة نيويورك ، هذا الموقع
في هارلم والآخر في
مرتفعات واشنطن هنا يتعاطى المستخدمون المخدرات غير المشروعة
بإمدادات نظيفة دون التعرض لخطر
الاعتقال لتوضيح ذلك  لا يتم إعطاؤهم
عقاقير قانونية هنا ، حيث
يتعاطون المخدرات التي بحوزتهم بالفعل عندما
يأتي شخص ما لأول مرة من الباب ،
وسنسألهم عما
يستخدمونه وكيف يستخدمونه في
موقع شرق هارلم ، كل هذا يتم تحت
الخارق  رؤية هؤلاء
المهنيين الطبيين مثل pia marcus ، هذه
جميع معدات الحقن والشم
لدينا بالإضافة إلى
معدات التدخين لدينا هنا حتى يتمكن الناس من أخذ
أي شيء يحتاجون إليه ، هل أنتم يا رفاق
رائعون ،
حسنًا
في مرتفعات واشنطن ، نفس
البروتوكولات الوقائية موجودة  مكان ولكن
هنا العديد من الموظفين المدربين يتعافون أيضًا من
المدمنين مثل كلارا كاردل ،
أرى أنك بحاجة إلى الماء ، فمن السهل جدًا بالنسبة
لي أن
أفهمهم ،
فهم ما يمرون به ،
سام ريفيرا هو المدير
التنفيذي للبرنامج الذي يقول إنهم تجنبوه
أكثر من 130 جرعة زائدة منذ افتتاح المواقع
في تشرين الثاني (نوفمبر) حتى الآن يقول ريفيرا إنه
لم يمت أي شخص تحت مراقبة الموظفين ،
وهذا لن يحدث إذا لم
تظهر بالطريقة التي تظهر بها
الرجل الهدف في نهاية اليوم
أعتقد أننا نتفق جميعًا على أننا نريد إبقاء
الناس على قيد الحياة
وإذا أردنا أن يتعافى الناس ويحصلوا
على حياة أفضل إذا ماتوا ،
فلا يمكنك أن تفعل ذلك جيدًا يا عزيزي ، فنحن نتحقق من
مشاركة الأشخاص  على الفور إذا بدأنا في رؤية
تدلي الجفن أو أي نوع من الترهل ،
فإننا نذهب
مباشرة وسنقوم بإثارة صرير القص
إذا رأينا جرعات زائدة أكثر خطورة
أو بدأت الجرعات الزائدة في
التقدم.  للذهاب فوق
عربة التحطم ، تحتوي عربة التحطم الخاصة بنا على
أكياس أمبو للممرات الهوائية عن طريق الفم ، نوعين مختلفين
من ناركان ، لذلك نحتفظ بجرعتين
مُعدَّتين بالفعل بحيث إذا كانت هناك
جرعة زائدة ونحتاج إلى استخدام نالوكسون ،
فهو جاهز بالفعل للذهاب عندما تنظر
إلى منشأة  على هذا
النحو ، فإن تفكيرك الفوري هو ما تفعله
لإبعاد هؤلاء الأشخاص عن المخدرات ، فنحن نمنحهم
كل فرصة ممكنة للتوقف بمجرد أن
يقول أحدهم إنه مهتم ،
فنجعلهم ينتقلون إلى التخلص من السموم ، وهناك
عملية كاملة في مكان قريب من هذه
الزاوية  ستجد
موقع الحقن الخاضع للإشراف في الجزء العلوي من الكتلة ،
وستجد أكبر منشأة لمعالجة الميثادون
في مدينة نيويورك ،
جوشوا كلينان هو عضو في
تحالف هارلم الأكبر الذي
تشعر منظمته بالقلق حياله  لقد أصبح
الحي بالفعل مشبعًا
جدًا بأكثر من عشرة منشآت متعلقة بالمخدرات ،
لقد استضفنا بالفعل أكثر
من حصتنا العادلة ونحن فخورون
بالقيام بذلك ولكننا نحتاج حقًا إلى
مجتمعات أخرى لتحمل بعضًا من هذا
العبء ، يقول كلاينان إنه ليس كذلك  فوجئت
بمحاولة فتح نوع مماثل من
المرافق في فيلادلفيا فشلت بعد
رد فعل عنيف من المجتمع هناك ، لا أريد
هذا في الحي الذي أعيش فيه أو أي شخص
آخر تظل هذه المراكز غير قانونية
بموجب القانون الفيدرالي الذي ينص على أنه
لا يمكنك تشغيل أو امتلاك مساحة أو تأجيرها
لاستخدامها  مواد غير قانونية
ولكن عندما فتحت هذه المواقع في مدينة نيويورك
عمدة المدينة السابق بيل دي
بلاسيو صاغ خطاب الدعم هذا ، فإن
وكالات المدينة على استعداد لضمان
الإطلاق الناجح الذي يتضمن
التزامًا بعدم اتخاذ
إجراءات تنفيذية ضد عملياتها
، يظهر أيضًا عمدة نيويورك الجديد إيريك آدامز
لدعمهم ، ومؤخراً
أعلنت وزارة العدل أنها تقيم
ما إذا كان يمكن فتح مواقع مثل هذه على
الصعيد الوطني  Id هل لديك مخاوف من أن
الحكومة الفيدرالية في نهاية اليوم
ستنظر وتقول لقد رأينا ما فعلته
ولا نوافق على لا ، أنا لا أفعل حقًا
لأن هذا تدخل
صحي
هذا
يعمل حقًا في الوقت الحالي ، يسعد الناس مثل
مونيكا دياز أن هناك مكانًا جديدًا أكثر أمانًا
لاستخدامه
كما هو الحال بالنسبة لليوم الذي لا تضطر فيه إلى
فعل ذلك ،
فلديك أفكار حول التنظيف
يبدو أنها بعيدة ولكن لا
بأس بها